ist das die lösung es scheint fast so
die schwerkraft im weltraum ist ja 0 und
auf dem mars und deutsche geringer als
sie auf der erde
das hat fatale folgen für astronauten
astronauten selbst mit gezieltem
training droht im all enormer
muskelschwund ein us forschungsteam hat
jetzt ja einen möglichen man muss sagen
wirkliches wundermittel gegen dieses
massive probleme der raumfahrt
aufgespürt aber es ist vielleicht
gefährlich wenn es mit anderen
medikamenten zusammenkommt klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt's täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's dann
bekommt ihr die - und verpasst war
zuerst und werbefrei der link ist und
wie hier und in der video beschreibung
herzlich willkommen eine reise ins all
ist echt alles andere als entspannung
die raumfahrt ist tatsächlich eine große
belastung für den menschlichen
organismus studien haben gezeigt dass
astronaut den astronauten im weltraum
regelrecht heiß laufen die diagnose
weltraum fieber aber auch die sehkraft
wird im all beeinträchtigt ebenfalls
ausgelöst durch die minimale schwerkraft
dort noch nicht nur das ist eine fatale
folge der verringerten schwerkraft ohne
gegenmassnahmen führt sie nämlich auch
zum muskel und knochenabbau und die
fitness der astronautinnen und
astronautinnen geht verloren ein großes
risiko
nicht umsonst müssten die teams nach
ihrer reise ins all erst einmal wieder
lernen auf der erde zu laufen kein
wunder denn obwohl jeden tag
krafttraining auf dem programm steht
geht die rückenmuskulatur im all um etwa
20 prozent zurück und das schon nach ein
paar monaten
der sogenannte soleos muskel in der wade
der schrumpft sogar bei einem
dreiwöchigen aufenthalt schon immer als
sogar um ein drittel ein drittel
das muss man sich mal vorstellen in nur
drei wochen und dadurch den muskelfasern
verloren die für ausdauernde bewegung
nötig sind in einer sogenannten badge
studie des deutschen zentrums für luft-
und raumfahrt dlr werden zurzeit die
auswirkungen der schwerelosigkeit auf
den menschlichen körper untersucht ihr
passiert wirklich alles ihm liegen das
waschen essen und selbst der
toilettengang dafür gibt es dann rund
16.000 euro mann ist wichtiger teil der
weltraumforschung wir haben ja hier bei
kriegs um science-fiction urlaub
berichtet klar ist bislang nur sowohl
kraft als auch muskelmasse
gehen bei einem längeren aufenthalt im
all verloren auch gezieltes training
kann diesen muskel schon nicht komplett
verhindern und es gibt weitere
physiologische veränderungen zum
beispiel verschieben sich die
körperflüssigkeiten in richtung kopf was
folgen für das herz kreislauf system mit
sich bringt mit hilfe der dlr studie
sollen gegenmaßnahmen entwickelt werden
die diese negativen effekte der
schwerelosigkeit für frauen und männer
im alm indern doch jetzt hat ein us
forschungsteam im tierversuch ein
mögliches mittel gegen dem muskelschwund
einmal aufgespürt die rede ist von der
substanz resveratrol die beispielsweise
auch in weintrauben blaubeeren und
rotwein zu finden ist versuche mit
ratten leben tatsächlich nahe dass
dieser pflanzeninhaltsstoff zumindest
einen teil des muskelaufbaus verhindern
kann
schon frühere studien hatten diese
substanz untersucht demnach hilft dieses
antioxidans möglicherweise gegen
entzündungen herz-kreislauf-erkrankungen
und vielleicht kann es sogar krebs hemd
doch diese ergebnisse sind umstritten
die aktuelle studie des forschungsteams
der harvard medical school in boston
bezieht sich einzig und allein auf die
ergebnisse der tierversuche in den
experimenten wurden ratten in bestimmte
geschirr eingespannt so dass sie ihre
beinmuskeln nun auch zu 40 belassen
konnten das ist etwa vergleichbar mit
der schwerkraft auf dem mars die hälfte
der tiere bekam pro tag 150 milligramm
resveratrol pro kilogramm körpergewicht
verabreicht die kontrollgruppe dagegen
nicht letztere hatte nach zwei wochen
deutlich an muskelmasse und außerdem
auch angriff kraft verloren ganz anders
sah es aber bei den ratten aus die das
resveratrol bekommen hatten bei diesen
tieren war der verlust an muskelfasern
signifikant geringer so berichtet es das
forschungsteam in der neuen studie auch
wenn die muskelmasse dieser ratten etwas
abgenommen hatte war ihre griff kraft
gleich geblieben die fachleute wir sind
selbst allerdings noch nicht ganz wie
die substanz wirkt sie vermuten aber
dass das resveratrol auf den
zuckerhaushalt wirkt dazu
marien euro die an der studie beteiligt
war
resveratrol fördert das muskelwachstum
bei diabetischen mäusen indem es die
insulin intensivität und die glukose
aufnahme in die muskelfasern steigert
unsere ergebnisse unterstreichen das
therapeutische potential
von resveratrol heißt also die zellen
reagieren möglicherweise durch die gabe
von resveratrol stärker auf das hormon
insulin so kann mehr traubenzucker
aufgenommen werden was den muskel
wachsen lässt die ergebnisse liegen also
nahe dass dieser mechanismus die muskeln
schützt und verhindert dass trotz
verringerter schwerkraft weniger muskeln
abgebaut werden für anstehende
raumfahrtmissionen könnte das eine
wichtige erkenntnis sein die forschenden
aus den usa können sich gut vorstellen
dass nahrungsergänzungsmittel mit
resveratrol einen muskel erhalten den
effekt mit sich bringen könnten
natürlich in kombination mit gezielten
körperlichen training vorher sind aber
noch weitere untersuchungen notwendig
dazu heißt es in der studie
wir müssen noch herausfinden welche
mechanismen involviert sind und welche
effekte verschiedene dosen des
resveratrol auf männer und frauen haben
zudem ist es wichtig zu bestätigen dass
resveratrol keine schädlichen
wechselwirkungen mit anderen
medikamenten der astronauten haben wird
denn das ist ein wichtiger punkt gibt es
da in anführungszeichen kollisionen
zwischen den medikamenten die die
astronauten hatten sowieso nehmen müssen
und dem es wäre toll ja wichtige frage
eine andere interessante frage ist wann
betritt der erste deutsche den mond mit
dieser frage beschäftigt sich jakob von
breaking lab also anklicken hier
anschauen und den extrem coolen kanal
breaking laborieren bis dann bleibt dran